a manhunt is underway for the murderer
of 24 year old brianna kupfer
who is stabbed to death while working at
a high-end los angeles furniture store
the assailant is believed to be homeless
her father spoke to fox and friends this
morning and had a powerful message for
the city's leaders
i blame
what's endemic in our society right now
is that everybody seems to be oriented
on
giving back rights
and bestowing
favor on people
that
rob others of their rights i don't know
it's the politicians themselves but we
don't elect them because we think
they're great
we elect them because we think they can
do great things and it's all being lost
all we're doing is trying to divide
people and get angry
at everything around us and it's just
it's got to end
it's such a great point we don't elect
you because you're awesome
we elect you because you're supposed to
do the job that you signed up to do that
you ran to do
meanwhile in new york a community is
mourning after 19 year old crystal
nieves i hope i pronounced that right
was murdered in a cold-blooded burger
king robbery the suspect a teenager with
seven prior arrests is finally once
again behind bars crystal's mother
called for an end to this madness
maybe my daughter is not the first one
who died in this way
but i want my daughter to be the last
days later in times square the heart of
manhattan in new york city a homeless
ex-convict
allegedly killed an innocent woman by
shoving her in front of a moving train
new york's new mayor eric adams admitted
he doesn't he the mayor doesn't even
feel safe in the city's subway system
we're going to make sure new yorkers
feel safe in our subway system and they
don't feel that way now i don't feel
that way when i take the train every day
you know that was that was actually an
about-face from what he said originally
which was oh everything's okay lawrence
jones is fox and friends enterprise
reporter and a good friend he joins me
now lawrence thanks for being here
every time we see a tragedy
go ahead please
i'm so sorry brother when the mayor says
that you know he doesn't feel safe with
a full security detail that's just a lie
um that's just like projecting to the
citizens pretending to feel their pain
look i i try to be optimistic when it
comes to this mayor but if if it's
really gonna stop the bleeding
within new york city and across the
country it's gonna take more than
rhetoric to stop it he needs a strong
statement going after the da to say
enough is enough you know we got to stop
pretending that we don't know the
solution to this problem um you you get
the bad guys you cuff them
you put them behind bars and then you
make sure that they don't harm other
people for some reason the criminal
justice system has flipped around and
the victims i'm sorry the criminals get
more rights than the actual victims of
crimes um you know when you look at that
dad uh talking about his baby girl
brianna and and the sheer strength that
he shows in the in the middle of that
interview i don't know if i could do it
especially when you have elected leaders
that do nothing you know what's going to
happen pete and i hate to say this but
it's just the truth it's going to hit
them in their family the fact of the
matter is there is no shield no matter
if you are elected or not for for the
the madness that is happening across
america i was just in chicago yesterday
doing a live shot talking about the most
violent community in america in the most
violent block in america i was there
yesterday in the middle of the shoot
guy goes and commits a strong rob
robbery steals a car the guy that he was
stealing the car from he was also a
robbery as well so you got two people
that are shooting at each other both
stealing cars that that is america today
pete
wow yeah lawrence you know it almost i
don't want to say every time but
the vast majority of times it feels like
a heinous crime like this happens and
then it takes a day or two for us to
learn about the rap sheet of the
perpetrator we learned that violent
crimes are almost always preceded by
other violent crimes or other crimes
that are indicative of the character of
that individual what is it about these
das where they can't understand or they
are they willfully intentionally want to
block the backgrounds of people and say
well we're going to give you a fifth
chance or a sixth chance or a that's not
criminal justice reform that's just
pro-criminal
they're bought and paid for you got
george soros that went in and decided to
team up with eric holder the former
attorney general to make this happen
i've been covering this about three and
a half years
they are married to their ideology you
know i've heard all day people say well
you know it was a homeless population
they don't there is a money problem in
many of these cities that they can't
make sure that the homeless get into
mental health facilities and get them
housing that is a blatant lie la philly
any other major city if you look at the
documents they have the money to solve
and what we saw and i've been covering
this for three and a half years is when
you go into those encampments the
homeless uh population has been offered
resources but they don't want to follow
the rules that comes with those reasons
so if you check them in the treatment
facility they got a curfew they got to
make sure and these are people are
getting full meals they're getting close
they're getting all the stuff bought by
the taxpayer of course but when there's
rules in place you tell them like they
got a curfew and they got to stop doing
the drugs they don't want to do it so
you know what that they go back to the
street and they continue to do what they
want to do again you got to cut it the
head head off the snake and make sure
there is real justice for these victims
out here
lawrence nobody knows it better than you
uh you speak the truth and we really
appreciate uh your time tonight thank
you so much by the way quick uh quick
note in what i just read uh crystal
nieves
the suspect and that was not a teenager
my my mistake and uh we want to always
get it right
all right thank you lawrence hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else